اكيد مباراه لن تنسى بعد الفوز المشرف
تونس تبهر العالم باداء مميز مباراه للذكر
امام فرنسا لكن ما هي حكايه تونس مع الدور
الاول المنتخب التونسي ودع المونديال من
دوري المجموعات المره السادسه في تاريخ
المشاركته في المونديال فوست تونس هو
الاول لها على منتخب اوروبي في تاريخ
المونديال في ما كانت خساره فرنسا الاولى
امام منتخب عربي في كاس العالم تونس ودعت
المونديال المره الثانيه في تاريخها بعد
مونديال عام
1978 في تحقيق نفس النتائج فوز وتعادل
وخساره
مهاجم المنتخب التونسي وهبي الخزري يصبح
ثاني لاعب عربيه سجل في مونديال مختلفين
معادلا ايضا نجم الكره السعوديه السابق
سامي الجابر بتسجيل ثلاثه اهداف في تاريخ
المشاركاته في المونديال